right-hander lewis head making his first
open of the season has appeared in 18
games and he's done a really nice job
almost a strikeout and ending an era of
1.85 oh away we go as cedric mullins
walks slowly into the left-handed
batters box
cedric jumps on that pitch deep fly ball
way back in right field a rosarina looks
up and it's gone
cedric mullins with a lead off homer
and the orioles score first
well that's what i was talking about you
know you've lost 13 in a row you've only
scored 36 runs in those games so
any offense
especially lead off home run
much appreciated especially if you're
spencer watkins watch this go right to
where you can just drop the bat head
home run number 21. austin hayes steps
in two down nobody on a run in
a breaking ball just hit hard and
through the left side a bouncing single
for austin hayes another well struck
ball 101 miles per hour off the bat and
the orioles have a two out yet severino
over three yesterday
grounded in the left that's a base hit
austin hayes around third headed to the
plate he'll score and the orioles have a
two-nothing lead
rbi for pedro severino good extended at
bat for him over 100 miles per hour but
right at guys
you know on the ground this one finds a
hole because it's hit so hard 104 miles
per hour see wendell try to get to it
couldn't and then meadows i mean he has
to kind of reach kind of awkwardly
watkins has an era of 525 in eight games
seven starts and he is thrown twice
against the rays go at 244 six home runs
ground ball
deep short
and by the time martin got rid of it no
chance loco has reached base
now nelson cruz who had two home runs
last night breaks his back lines it out
of the reach of martin into left for a
visit
franco goes to second two on one out in
the range first so the rays trying to
put together an inning
and that will be ball four a little bit
wide
and that loads the bases if g-man choi
will match
enjoy a live drive base head into right
here comes franco cruz heads to the
plate he will score now they're going to
get choi hung up and he is tagged out
the reigns get two runs on the base hit
by joy now the curveball right there by
watkins and that was after the fastball
remember up and away to try to set that
pitch up choi great job a two
strike two out hitting
you're going to get those two runners
across but then the throw in from hayes
ends up getting cut by mount castle and
g-man choi was hung out to drive and he
was head wait halfway between first and
second base
brian yarbrough heads to the mound
one inning for
lewis head gave up a couple of runs i'll
tell you there's a swing at a miss
and
franco out on strikes orioles race tied
at two tampa bay second will be seven
eight nine joey wendell francisco mahia
and kevin kiermeier
against
spencer watkins
hit hard to right field diving and
making the play is austin hayes terrific
grab
good jump on that ball and then the dive
for the catch here's a terrific
outfielder he came up 2017. so that ball
is sinking a little bit and able to
track it
you know it has been well there's a
little looper in the left and that's
gonna hang up and
fall
mateo appeared to get there and could
not glove it
and mejia is going to wind up in second
bottom of the fourth coming with joey
wendell stepping in against spencer
watkins
there's a mate's head extra bases
and the left center cut off by mullins
and wendell on his way to second with
the double that's 26 double of the year
and now the rays
have the leadoff man and scoring
position in the fourth
brandon lau overloading the right side
for lau and he shoots it the other way a
base hit right over franco's head
inside the line and wendell scores the
go-ahead run
nice job by brandon lau just punching
the single
yeah exactly he's trying to pull that
pitch and look where his eyes go it's
his eyes go up and to the right side
and a little q shot
take it though he's off the pitch is up
and away and the throw
the
disconnect on the throw down there
martin couldn't hold it as he went
reaching to his left
and there's the base hit off the banner
franco back toward the corner that's
going to score lau bronco dicks for two
and he's in standing with a double
all three of the hits to the opposite
field you think about wendell getting it
started with the double then that ball
off the end of the bat by lau and then
right here franco stays on that pitch
very nicely
and shoots it out into left field and
look at that hustle off the bat he's
thinking i'm going to second base and he
does just that mateo gets it old gets
over to it gets it in francisco mejia
final game of the series in baltimore
that's a liner and it's off the glove of
iras
and into right field
it appeared that uranus might actually
catch that ball and it clipped his glove
should have i mean that's a line driving
you know not an easy play but this is
major league baseball
and a walk so that follows the error and
just like that the raise with two men on
and nobody out well brandon lau comes to
the plate here
and ball four so the error and two walks
and just like that the bases are loaded
with nobody out as wander franco to deal
with now
one two and a liner off the glove of
martin everybody's gonna be safe a run
will score
and the rays
make it a 5-2 game and here is nelson
cruz
liner into right field that's going to
stay out and be caught by hayes the tag
at third kirby's going to score
over to third goes lau
the rays
now make it a four run game it's 6-2
here's austin meadows
live all center field
mullins is there to make the catch
lau on the tag will come home easily
and the rays score their third round of
the innings they
run batted in number 80
on the year for austin meadows
jorge mateo trying to extend an
eight-game hit streak well-groomed beard
for kitridge
and there is a base hit the hit streak
extended to nine well you gotta like
that approach here comes michael two-two
look at the base head yeah
that'll get him around to third mateo
with that speed no play there
a little a
little wedge shot into right then here
comes austin wins one strike to wins and
that's into center field for a base hit
that'll get a run home mateo scores the
lead cut to 7-3 and two orioles on with
only one down brian trying to extend a
nine-game hit streak
there's three big swing way back in left
field
and it is gone
ryan montcastle
dramatically extends his streak and
maybe his final at bat of the game
with a home run number 20 for ryan
just one off the club lead hirmeyer to
the plate
in the first pitch he gets into this one
sends it deep into center field and
that's going to be off the wall extra
bases hit it second with a stand-up
double meadows who drove in a run with a
fly ball in the sixth
up the left side that's got a chance to
be fair it is and will bound
off the foul ball
kiermeyer has scored franco's going to
come around to score
and meadows
winds up at second
the rays
look for their 74th win of the season
3-2 fly ball into right field brett
phillips is there and the reigns win
this one
three up three down in the ninth for
baltimore the raids went at eight to
four
you